à
lever de soleil sur boulogne billancourt
2 degrés au thermomètre et pourtant au
12e étage on trouve un peu de chaleur
réunionnaise bienvenus oui j'ai donc
jeune william qui est chez moi depuis le
15 mai dames et tv l'une des premières
familles d'accueil agréée par le conseil
départemental une famille d'accueil
c'est aussi un lien social c'est un lien
avec le réunion le jeune réunionnais qui
vient ici j'ai quitté la réunion par
désir mais j'aime bien aussi avoir des
contacts avec mon île puis ça l'aide
aussi à s'insérer au départ c'est si
vous voulez pour le permettre au départ
de ne pas sentir isolé complètement
arrivé ici toutes ces années un hôtel ou
alors une chambre carrément cher pour
moi je pense que j'ai un peu rangé la
voie à s'aimer chemise de travail chez
vous pour un bac pro
dans la restauration enfin service en
salle et pour pouvoir enfin ensuite être
embauchés par le patron qui mouille
actuellement qui m'appelait enfin qui
m'a embauché pour un contrat
d'apprentissage heures première étape de
cet accompagnement le projet
professionnel
une démarche validée par le cnam comité
national d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité qui a une
antenne dans le 4e arrondissement de
paris dans les critères c'est de
s'assurer que la personne il vient dans
une démarche d'emploi donc qu'elle
vienne en métropole donc pour une
insertion durable
donc à partir du moment où son projet
validé par nos collègues donc à la
réunion et vérifier notamment par les
agents du cnam de métropole on s'assure
donc candidat est toujours occupée pour
son projet de mobilité qu'il est prêt à
venir travailler en luttant par notre
mission ne s'arrête pas uniquement bien
évidemment à l'emploi ça s'arrête ça ça
se poursuit donc par
l'accompagnement au logement
l'accompagnement à l'installation donc
on reçoit des candidats qui ont de la
famille dans le conte s'assure que le
projet de vie et bien travaillé et que
le candidat est volontaire donc pour
s'installer dans les maisons qu'on va
nous proposer que ça peut être en foyer
de jeunes travailleurs ça peut être
également résidence d'étudiants et
notamment en famille d'accueil
puisqu'on a des familles d'accueil
conventionné par le conseil général
ainsi régulièrement une rencontre a lieu
entre un réunionnais fraîchement
débarqués et la famille d'accueil
bien entendu chaque parti a des
obligations mais rapidement les valeurs
de solidarité prennent le parti attend
paysage du matin ah oui j'adore il ya
une belle vue par ici enfin à boulogne
ne m'attendais pas à être dans la
famille d'accueil
mais comme j'ai fait des démarches enfin
j'ai pas eu trop le temps de faire des
manches pour me trouver un logement
b le cadre de la mobilité
ils ont changé enfin de mettre dans un
famille d'accueil le ton jeu je puisse
me trouver un logement des obligations
d'une famille d'accueil
donc on a le chef chez nous on a le
petit déjeuner donc et le repas du soir
un repas bon et quelquefois il ya des
jeunes qui travaillent
s'ils travaillent le soir eh ben c'est
le repas du midi et après ça devient
sais c'est un peu comme l'enfant de la
maison après un
il fait partie de la famille c'est ça
c'est l'avantagé la famille d'accueil
c'est aussi qui se sent bien chez nous
parce qu'il faut savoir aussi une chose
c'est que si jamais où le jeune moi même
l'un des deux parties ça ne va pas il
peut mais il peut voir ja il pas aller
ailleurs
y'a pas de soucis bonne journée
ambrosini ainsi un acteur un talent
déjà 8h30 comme chaque matin william pas
reprendre son service dans un restaurant
parisien
trois mois d'un contexte habits lisez
pour prendre un bon départ
metropolit j'ai quitté la réunion j'ai
fait onze mille kilomètres c'est pas
pour abandonner aussi et je me suis dit
quelles que soient les circonstances
j'irai jusqu'au bout au moins de pouvoir
réussir et pouvoir faire un trou dans ma
vie